Build It.
Draw It.
Play It.
Vsauce!
This is your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people.
This is BiDiPi.
Build It.
Tom Cuthbert and Daniel Valdez built an animatronic
Admiral Ackbar costume.
The eye movement of the mask is hooked up
to Daniel's glasses - there's a fan inside
to keep it cool inside and there are several
servo mechanisms to control it.
And here he is at Dragon Con with the full
costume.
Doktor A is an english artist who creates
incredible steam punk toys.
The prolific artist has a ton of original
sculptures and toys on his website spookypop
and he uses a variety for materials including
brass, vinly rubber and steel as well as found
objects to bring his wild imagination to life.
Find the link below for more.
Jon English is a toy builder that creates
his own Masters Of The Universe figures.
His deviantart page is filled with custom
interpretations of original toys as well as
entirely new characters.
Including War Wolf, Swamp Chomp and Sintaur.
This Batcave was built out of 20,000 LEGO
bricks.
Carlyle Livingston and Wayne Hussey put more
than 800 hours into this piece that weighs
over 100 pounds and it also features LED christmas
and flash lights.
Draw It.
Maniac Pumpkin Carvers is the work of Marc
Evan and Chris Soria.
Both artists do illustration and visual design
on their own but combine their talents to
carve some of the coolest pop culture-inspired
pumpkins that are available for online ordering
at maniacpumpkincarvers.com.
Dit Von Tease creates finger portraits of
famous figures.
The Italian artist has dubbed the project
Ditology features manipulated finger photos
depicting everyone from Captain Spock and
Mr. T to Mickey Mouse and Mozart.
And now for the comic book artistry of Australia's
Tristan Jones...
Happy Little Trees is a tribute to PBS painting
legend Bob Ross going on at the screaming
sky gallery - find the link below to check
out more of the awesomely Afro-y prints...
Play It.
The Bubble Organ was built by Aaron Wendell
and directs airflow to harness the sound of
bubbles...
Comedian and musician Matt Griffo just released
this music video for his song Ghosts, Ghouls,
Goblins and some guy named Gary Greg...
AVbyte brings us The Walking Dead Musical...
Finally, an animated crocheted octopus is
star of Wax Tailor's video for the song Time
To Go...
Submit your BiDiPis as a personal message
here on YouTube.
Or share them with everyone at Facebook.com/VsauceGaming.
Click here for a brand the 10th installment
of BiDiPi Radio music created and submitted
by you guys.
Also check out Your BiDiPi - an entire video
of your creations.
And as always thanks for watching.